you know something that the american
right wing
does a lot
they project and i don't mean they
project movies onto the side of a
building i'm going to talk about a
literal projector here what i mean is
they accuse the left of the doing that
which they themselves actually do and
there are so many different areas in
which we could talk about this but one
of those areas recently has really
scaled up a lot to include claims that
the left is brainwashing children
into
their own dogmas often through critical
race theory or through college which is
many believe is liberal indoctrination
or in other ways they're going after the
kids
it turns out that it's actually the
right that is doing this and a viewer
sent me a link to some
toe-curling trump propaganda aimed at
kids
with former arkansas republican governor
mike huckabee involved as well you have
to see this because this is them doing
what they accuse the left of doing
this is something called
the kid's guide
to president trump
and if you go to the website
which i i mean i guess we'll link to it
i don't know it's not like we're not
promoting it but you should be able to
look at this for yourselves there's a
picture of mike huckabee
and it's promoted as help your kids
learn the truth about president trump
and celebrate america with this free
patriotic gift bundle
mike huckabee co-founder of the kids
guide and one of the products is called
the kid's guide to donald trump it has
drawings of trump
swearing in uh his
swearing his oath of office with his
hand on a bible being held by abraham
lincoln if you want to look at some
propaganda
um and here's everything you get with
this bundle you get the kids guide to
president trump
you get to learn our learn our histories
great again restoring faith in america
streaming video and it's like a run-on
sentence it's just crazy and then you
also get the ever bright kids magazine
which is more right-wing trash bundled
um
for children this free gift bundle will
look at the language help your kids
learn
all about trump's greatest
accomplishments during his first term
first term i like that
give your kids a sneak peek inside the
trump presidency and look at look at the
description here and i'll zoom in on it
for you
the mainstream media
has been no friend to president trump
they market this as like history
material the mainstream media has been
no friend to president trump and they'll
never admit that he did a great job
leading our country and making the
changes america needs give us a list of
those changes
but as future voters our children and
grandchildren deserve to understand the
truth about trump and what made him a
great president
this is what they say the left is doing
you could not get something more
cartoonishly insane than this
that's why we're giving away our free
patriotic kids bundle to help your kids
and grandkids learn the truth about
trump and his accomplishments this fun
bundle includes the things i told you
about you get them both for just a
dollar shipping and processing each
the kids guide to president trump is
unbiased
and will help your kids learn everything
there is to know from his election in
2016 and his greatest accomplishments as
an added bonus we're giving you
unlimited access to the great again
restoring faith in america video and
digital work workbook what's more the
special issue of everbright kids
magazine will help your kids celebrate
america and enjoy oodles just oodles and
oodles of great content and activities
to keep them entertained for hours
um
oh and by the way it's sort of one of
these subscription grips because look at
this as part of the special offer your
kids can look forward to a new kids
guide covering an important topic for
kids once a month including a streaming
video lesson and workbook all for just
and ninety cents plus we'll send your
kids a new issue of ever break kids
magazine each month for only five
dollars and seventy five cents
oh my god it's a financial grift as much
as it is a political great it's this is
the indoctrination
this is the propaganda they say you know
you send your kids to college they're
going to get indoctrinated um you send
your kids to school
there might be teachers teaching
critical race theory or there might be
teachers um uh uh
you teaching other stuff
but with the framework of critical race
theory
this is the propaganda guys
this is the propaganda the kid's guide
for patriotic kids
with the truth about president donald
trump
toe-curling
propaganda toe-curling propaganda
absolutely horrible stuff